what I would argue is we're seeing the
ongoing influence of the luxury belief
class in this country people who pursue
and Advocate policies like open borders
like relaxed policies on refugees and
illegal migrants who will not suffer the
cost of those policies but which will
impose enormous costs on other people
like the mother and the two daughters
who who suffered this horrific attack
that's what we have in this country an
Elite Class within the institutions
within the Church of England within the
the Charities the courts who are
routinely advocating luxury beliefs that
bring them very few if any cost but
seriously impact in a negative way the
ways of life for ordinary British people
that is ultimately at the heart of this
this isn't really about Abdul aidi this
is actually about the new Elite who are
running the institutions in this country
who have a fundamentally different view
of these issues than the vast majority
of British people who have to live with
the consequences of them